we all know how dangerous climbing Mount
Everest can be historically over 300
people died attempting to reach the
summit in 2019 alone it claimed the
lives of 11 people yet despite the risk
its sheer magnitude and beauty inspires
around 800 climbers a year to flock to
the mountain but what if we stepped it
up a notch and made Everest even more
dangerous
imagine this peaceful giant was an angry
volcano waiting to burst how's that for
an adrenaline rush what would happen if
Everest erupted how would it affect the
rest of the world
but we prevent it and others like it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Mount Everest was an active
volcano there are 1500 active volcanoes
around the world and many of them found
deep in the ocean yet there are only 20
super volcanoes on earth
if Everest was one of them and happened
to be sitting on a giant pool of magma
ready to explode we'd be in serious
trouble to put this into perspective the
largest eruption on record Mount Tambora
happened in 1815 on the Indonesian
island of Samoa at only half the size of
Mount Everest it was once a four
thousand meter tall stratovolcano which
melted down to an 11,000 109 meter deep
caldera this classifies it as a
supervolcano as it initially erupted
over 1,000 cubic meters of material
around 43,000 years ago on the volcanic
explosivity index the 1815 eruption of
Mount Tambora earned the highest ranking
ever recorded with the
I seven classification the most
catastrophic eruptions ranking at a vei
eight happened thousands and millions of
years ago the explosion of Mount Tambora
sent volcanic ash kilometres up into the
sky destroying crops and burying entire
villages it triggered earthquakes and
possibly large tsunamis the release of
Ash and aerosols in the stratosphere
blocked the Sun causing nearby
temperatures to drop this made food and
oxygen scarce killing over 100,000
people hikes
so if everest happened to be a volcano
ready to burst what would happen despite
everest being a whopping eight thousand
eight hundred and forty nine meters tall
in the world of volcanoes and
relationships size doesn't always matter
it's what's inside that counts
deep below a volcano beneath the earth's
mantle is a magma chamber waiting to
blow skyward it's hard to say how big
everest its magma chamber might be but
it would have to be pretty large to send
magma high enough to reach the surface
if you happen to summit Everest on this
fateful day you'd be vaporized in
seconds giant chunks of burning rock
also known as volcanic bombs would be
flung outward crushing villages and
smothering them with ash
a flaming hot avalanche would decimate
everything in its path all five
countries circling Everest including
Nepal India Pakistan
Boutin and the People's Republic of
China would be absolutely devastated
many earthquakes would trigger along the
indo-australian and Eurasian fault lines
essentially this would be very bad news
for everyone but it gets worse to add
insult to injury the release of ash into
the stratosphere would block the Sun
triggering a volcanic winter that could
last for several years
this would destroy crops and the United
Nations estimates earth would run out of
food in just over two months if there
were any survivors they would probably
be deep in a bomb shelter somewhere
hoarding a lifetime supply of food and
toilet paper there is some light at the
end of this tunnel though after about a
hundred years all these gases would
actually start to warm the climate again
but that's a long wait for a volcanic
summer if anybody actually survived this
climbing Everest would be a whole new
experience and probably a lot easier to
accomplish as a much smaller and
hollowed-out caldera you could finally
check that off your bucket list but
let's rewind what if we knew Everest was
going to explode what could we do as it
turns out scientists at NASA have an
almost four billion dollar solution it
would involve drilling a series of wells
around the perimeter of the volcano to
send ice-cold water down to the magma
chamber this in turn would form a
protective ring of cool rock to help
prevent a cataclysmic burst
as the water heats up NASA would extract
it at the surface for electric power
generation talk about a win-win mind you
if they happen to drill in a sensitive
area there is a chance they could
actually trigger an eruption which would
be the biggest base poem in the history
of humanity just support you at ease
everest is not a volcano and will never
erupt Sherpas and climbers will stay in
business for a long time yet there are a
number of super volcanoes on earth
building pressure these eruptions are
extremely rare as pressure building
isn't always what triggers a volcanic
event unlike earthquakes volcanoes are
much harder to predict with that said
Yellowstone America's supervolcano is
supposedly overdue but that's a story
for another what-if
[Applause]
you